تنظيم وهيكلة الدولة. واشنطن
تواصل زحفها نحو حدود روسيا لكن
ساعة والا نفذوا تهديدهم. الرئيس
المصري نعمل بهدوء على اعادة
هل يدرك الامريكان ان زحفهم هذا
يقربهم نحو النهاية التي قد تكون
اسرائيل مستمرة ضد برنامج ايران
النووي. قراصنة بلاك بيبون في
نقص حاد في الكهرباء. فعن اي
امداد نتحدث لترتفع اصوات
الشمالية بحسب وكالة يوناب. فما
الذي يخطط له المجنون؟ الجزائر
اوروبا في كارثة. بينما يتصاعد
الغضب في اوروبا والاحتجاجات
نحقق نجاحات في كل المعارك. لكن
المعركة لم تنتهي بعد. ومعركة
من جديد. يخطط الشاب العربي
للهجرة ها هو الشاب البريطاني
يفكر بها حيث كشفت دراسة
بريطانية ان ملايين من
فقام بقصف البنية التحتية للطاقة
الاوكرانية بشكل كامل ليخرج هنا
تفرض عقوبات على الجزائر. فلم كل
ابناء العم سام وهنا الرئاسة
وزير الطاقة الاوكراني ويعلن
اعتذاره عن عدم قدرة بلاده على
الروسية ليستغل بوتين هذه الفرصة
الذهبية لخنق اوروبا باحكام.
المتظاهرين في بريطانيا مطالبين
بعودة الانضمام للاتحاد الاوروبي
حول اوكرانيا. وفي لحظة سهو
المعلومة تقع في يد الاستخبارات
طريق انضمام اليابان الى تحالف
العيون الخمس وهو اشبه بالجروب
امداد اوروبا بالكهرباء الموعودة
بينما اوكرانيا الان تعاني من
البريطانيين اليوم يخططون للهجرة
والسبب غلاء المعيشة وذلك بحسب
الروسي بفائض انتاج ثلاثمائة
وخمس واربعين محطة مختلفة للطاقة
او النافذة الهدف منها تبادل
المعلومات الاستخباراتية بين
متسارع وهذا ما يقلق امريكا في
الاونة الاخيرة التي كادت ان
يغيب عن القمة العربية لاسباب
صحية. رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي.
الجزائرية تصرح ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
اختراق الطاقة الذرية الايرانية
ويمهلون النظام اربعا وعشرين
وتعزز موسكو والجزائر من
تقاربهما في المجال العسكري بشكل
مجلة تايماوت. الاحداث
والتطورات. كوريا الجنوبية تطلق
عيارات تحذيرية بعد اشتباهها
بتوغل حدودي حربية لكوريا
موانئ اوروبا الى بكين. نعم يا
اصدقائي الصين تفجر خلافا بين
وثلاثين في المائة من ميناء
هامبورج ما اثار جدلا داخل
للبيت الابيض رأي اخر قائلا بان
العالم ليس غبيا في حال استخدم
وروسيا تنفذان مناورات بحرية
مشتركة تمهيدا لدرع الصحراء
فماذا عن قذارة الحروب الغربية
في الاراضي العربية? الصين تهدد
منحى اخر. فعندما كان زيلينسكي
يخطط لتعويض اوروبا عن الغاز
استراليا وبريطانيا وكندا
ونيوزيلندا والولايات المتحدة.
العسكري للصين وتبادل المزيد من
المعلومات الاستخباراتية الحساسة
وتوقع مع استراليا اتفاقا امنيا
تاريخيا يهدف الى مواجهة الصعود
تتوسع في عدة بلدان بسبب غلاء
الاسعار وازمة الطاقة. هنا تأخذ
وتعزيز التعاون العسكري بينما
يرى البعض في الاتفاق خطوة على
المانيا والمفوضية الاوروبية.
لتأتي هنا اليابان في المشهد
ماذا عن من يسبقك بخطوتين هنا?
الصين تضرب الاتحاد الاوروبي في
اوروبا. من يسبقك بخطوة سينتصر
عليك في المواجهة? لا محالة لكن
استثمارا بهذا الحجم قد يؤدي
لتسريب معلومات حساسة عن نشاط
المانيا وضاعف مخاوف دول اوروبا.
حيث قالت المفوضية الاوروبية ان
مقتل بينما يسعى الاتحاد لمكافحة
الصيني المتسارع في جميع
هذا الادعاء كذريعة تصعيد عن
القنبلة القذرة يتحدثون. اذا
قنبلة قذرة في اوكرانيا لاتهام
روسيا باستخدام السلاح النووي
المجالات. هنا عملاق الشحن
الصيني كوسكو يستحوذ على خمسة
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني القنبلة
القذرة فكرة بغيضة وندعو الوكالة
للقنبلة القذرة. فعن اي قذارة
نتحدث نظام كييف يحضر لاستخدام
المعارك الدامية. حيث طالبت
السلطات الموالية لروسيا ما تبقى
من سكان خرسون بسرعة المغادرة
فورا. فما الذي تخطط له موسكو في
بالقنبلة القذرة الاسلحة النووية
منخفضة القوة. ايعقل هذا؟ ليرد
الدولية للطاقة الذرية لارسال
مراقبين لاوكرانيا. ولكن كان
بحسب وكالة سبوتنيك الروسية.
ووفقا للمصادر والمعلومات
لنظيره الفرنسي في اتصال هاتفي
موسكو من استخدام اوكرانيا
الروسية ويسبب اضرارا كارثية،
فكيف سترد موسكو ليأتي الرد من
خرسون يا ترى? وعلى الارض ايضا
كان وزير الدفاع الروسي قد نقل
مسؤول روسي؟ الناتو يقترب من
مستوى الخطر وهذا ينذر بصيد وشيك
الواردة فان نظام كييف يستعد
لاستفزاز موسكو بتفجير ما يسمى
مع روسيا. فهل وصلت الرسالة? ومن
المعارك الكلامية الى ارض
طيار. لكنني متأكد من اننا
بالتدريج سنحقق ذلك بمساعدة ونحن
الروسي سيرجي شويغو. فلماذا كل
تلك الخطوات ايها الامريكان وكيف
لكم ان تضعوا جنودكم بالقرب من
روسيا كمن يضع البنزين بجانب
يزيد الطين بلة هو قصف اوكراني
مرة اخرى يطال منطقة بالقرود
مائة بالمائة من الصواريخ
الروسية وضرب الطائرات بدون
النار? يصرح هنا. بالطبع ليست
لدينا القدرة التقنية على تدمير
بالفعل الان نسقط اغلبية صواريخ
كروز والطائرات بدون طيار. وما
الذي شاركه وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لويد اوستن عند اتصاله بنظيره
موسكو بخطوة مماثلة لتعلن حينها
عن بداية الحرب العالمية الثالثة
لكن مهلا لا تذهب بعيدا. فهنا
وزيرة الخارجية الفرنسية كاترين
شبكة سي بي اس نيوز فان الفرقة
التي يبلغ قوامها اربعة الاف
ويقول اذا كان هناك تصعيد عسكري
او هجوم على الناتو نحن مستعدون
على الابقاء على قنوات الاتصال
مع روسيا مفتوحة وهو الرأي ذاته
ثلاثة اميال فقط من حدود رومانيا
مع اوكرانيا. ليخرج قائد الفرقة
كما اننا على استعداد تام لعبور
الحدود ودخول اراضي اوكرانيا.
كولونة تحذر من خطر تعزيز عزلة
بوتين العالق حسب قولها مشددة
وسبعمائة جندي تتمركز في رومانيا
في اقصى حدود الناتو على بعد
لا الخير من بعدها تقترب من
اوكرانيا وهي ذات الفرقة التي
عبثت في العراق وافغانستان فرقة
المهمات الصعبة لواشنطن. وبحسب
امريكا تتجاهل تحذيرات بوتين
وتدس السم في العسل فهل ترد
تتحرش عسكريا بسفن المجنون
الحربية. امريكا تصب الزيت على
لتنفيذ مطالبهم. والجزائر تصرح
سلمان يعتذر وكوريا الجنوبية
النار. من هؤلاء الجنود وما الذي
يفعلونه بالقرب من حدود
تخترق برنامج ايران النووي
وتعطيه مهلة اربعا وعشرين ساعة
والمانيا في خطر. تستعين
باستراليا لمواجهة الصين، فهل
روسيا وبوتين يقول هكذا اردتموها
وهكذا اريدها انا، ومجموعة هاكرز
الهي هل حان وقت الدمار والخراب?
الصقور الصارخة? او الفرقة التي
يثمن هذا الحلف او يغني من جوع؟
واوروبا في كارثة حقيقية بسبب
اوكرانيا? اليست هذه الفرقة
الامريكية مئة وواحد? نعم. يا
Deepak
America. فورا والزلنسكي يرد.
والكرملين يحذر اوكرانيا مجددا
spending. We're changing
people's lives.
I don't want to hear anymore of
these lies about reckless
من استخدام القنبلة القذرة.
والصين تخترق الاتحاد الاوروبي
نهاية ليس لامريكا فقط.